so don't be deterred by a no in any way
frankly i got
so many no's in 2017 but
um there and obviously there were
self-doubt moments as well i was like oh
my god am i doing this the right way i
don't know what's going on
[Music]
spandanapalapu thank you so much for
joining me all the way from the united
arab emirates how are you
good good thank you thank you for having
me thank you very much for being here i
just came back from a wonderful trip
to dubai it was remarkable eye-opening
and getting to know a whole new very
similar yet very different culture i'm
calling from tel aviv
and i think that although uh although
the locals in dubai and
and israelis are are very similar in a
lot of ways there's a lot of cultural
differences in
how business is done how relationships
are are formed so i think it was very
fascinating
i'm glad to hear that no um i mean
considering everything's opened up now
i'm just glad to see that you know
things are promising in the right
direction a hundred percent
and when we're waiting for you here in
tel aviv but in the meantime i'll have
to
gauge your your brain here in these next
20 minutes
spantana you've had a remarkable you
know journey
leading up to zoe's and i'd love to to
to focus on that as well
but first i have to go back and
understand a little bit about your
passions and the different things that
you've done
from the different speaking engagements
and being ambassador of different
organizations
uh i actually also participated in the
epgy program at stanford just like you
did
and but tell me a little bit about tell
me a little bit about about what's been
happening with you up until now
um so honestly like just a regular 25
year old if you ask me
um the whole drive around education and
employment that was
always instilled in me as a child to be
honest i've always been
the kind of person that was into
community service
and doing things in relation to
education i used to teach in high school
and i used to teach kids from
underprivileged backgrounds and i used
to teach children with learning
with learning disabilities as well so
you know education and employment have
always been
very close to my heart and
i also come from a very strong
entrepreneurial family so like my dad's
an entrepreneur my uncles are
entrepreneurs so
um you know that i think also kind of
instilled a little bit of that business
part within me when i was
younger and i knew that
i wanted to do something that was in
relation to education
employment or health care but i didn't
really know what was the right path to
kind of pursue for that do i go into
medicine because medicine was something
that i had considered at one point
or do i go into business and being from
a traditional south indian
family you know business business is
usually
like a weary subject to choose you
either go into engineering or you go
into
medicine those are your two key career
choices
but i remember sitting my parents down
and like taking them through this entire
decision matrix of why i thought like
business was the right option
and post post university honestly
it reached a point where um i wanted to
actually go into consulting before you
know starting my own social enterprise
because ultimately that was the end goal
but as i was applying for jobs and
um you know i even got an offer from
a big four at the same time i was also
working on zoe z as an idea because i
i mean growing up in the uae you do get
to interact with people from
diverse backgrounds different walks of
life and a big part of that is the
blue-collar community
and um so you know hearing their stories
is
truly you know it's it's a remarkable
experience because
you meet engineers who are working as
cleaners you meet
waiters um who actually have teaching
backgrounds
so you know these are people that are
actually skilled but end up
in different circumstances mainly
because of
middle men and brokers in their home
countries who sell them a dream which is
very
different to reality and in the process
they even pay
almost three thousand dollars to find
employment abroad
you know so that was when
that that spark kind of instilled within
me and i knew that this was like
this was my purpose and my passion and
so
when somebody somebody had come forward
and shown an interest in investing in so
easy so that was when i decided okay
let's give this path a try and see see
how that goes
i'd love to understand a little bit more
about this about you know the
circumstances when you say blue color
what do you mean by that
so anybody that so in the uae of a
blue-collar worker is essentially
defined as somebody that earns
about 5 000 dirhams or less um
and you have a variation of these
these professions so it ranges from
unskilled to skilled
to semi-skilled and what i mean by
unskilled is
so for example somebody if you ask
somebody to pick up a box and put it
somewhere like
some something like that that would be
considered an unskilled
person but it can also go up to a skill
level where
you know sometimes some nurses and some
some nurses are also considered
as a part of the blue slash gray color
industry so it's a very wide
variation so it ranges from waiters to
the construction industry hospitality
facilities management a lot of that a
lot of people that work in these
industries fall into the blue color
community
and there are almost four million
blue-collar workers in the uae so that's
43 foreign it's a massive yeah
it's a massive number it's a huge part
of the community um
so you get to interact with them on a
regular basis and
that's how i grew up you know like i i
was always exposed
um to different nationalities different
communities different backgrounds
and so that's where you hear about these
stories
so tell me a little bit about about zoe
and what were what were some of the
insights that you've gained on how to
potentially tackle
these you know these circumstances that
obviously are not ideal
of course um so like i mentioned of
as i was doing my research and speaking
to more people
you know i realized that it's not
actually a problem that starts
in the uae it's a problem that starts
at the very source from the country that
these these job seekers are coming from
they're coming to the uae to find better
employment opportunities
and honestly i have come across many
people
who yes have come here under a certain
pretext
but after joining the firm and
understanding that there are ethical
employers out here
they have they have been able to save up
and
create a better standard of living for
their families back home at the end of
it
but what we aim to do and what we
want to bring as a change to the whole
system is essentially removing
this network of middlemen because both
employers
and job seekers have to go through about
six layers of middlemen before
an employee is actually hired so
employers aren't exactly benefiting
because there's no other alternatives in
the market you know
you have a lot of white-collar talent
platforms out there but you don't have
anything that's catering to the blue
collar community
and so in the process you have to rely
on this paper-based archive system
and a lot of employers do pay for
they pay these middlemen recruitment
fees but they end up with job seekers
that
aren't exactly the right fit for what
they're looking for
similarly job seekers don't exactly have
the right guidance or skills to be able
to find
employment opportunities that are in
line with their career as
career aspirations you know and so in
the process
they this is the only method that's out
there this has been happening for the
last 40 to 50 years there's no other
alternatives
in the in the industry and so you rely
on a middleman
who sells you this wonderful dream oh
you're going to be right next to the
butch khalifa it's going to be a great
great job great experience for you and
that message that the employer puts
forward gets completely diluted by the
time it reaches the job seeker
so in the process employers aren't happy
job seekers aren't happy
both have shed money because it goes to
the middlemen so it's not a win-win for
either
party to be honest and that's what we're
trying to tackle you know
ensure that good employers get access to
good people
and good people get access to the right
employment opportunities so that they
can create a better standard of living
for their families back home
and you mentioned that a part of it part
of the distance that we have here is
that
people that have certain skill sets they
don't actually
come to fruition and and you know
locally in the uae where you're
specifically
looking at how is zoe's actually
compromising on that right so um
we actually so one we we did a pilot
placement actually we wanted to
understand how the system worked
and um what the issues were
around this whole sector and you don't
really have a lot of data
out there in relation to this industry
unless you go
and you tackle this firsthand yourself
so
we did a pilot placement of 150 people
we also generated a massive database but
from within that database we chose 150
people
150 job seekers that we could place
within different industries
so we looked at industries like
construction hospitality
um and so on and
we understood what the hindrances were
offline and what were the processes that
we could move
online to make the system more ethical
and more
transparent and that could also help job
seekers showcase their skills in better
ways
so that's where we came up with the
concept of implementing things like
video cvs and live interviewing because
many of these job seekers
don't know how to write good cvs but
they know how to express themselves
really well
so that's where these tools will come in
to provide
a more holistic perspective of the job
seeker and that also reduces a lot of
like the
the travel costs that are involved for
employers who
would otherwise have to travel to india
or travel to
parts of southeast asia in order to be
able to recruit people
from the ground you know what i mean
right
right so just for just for you know for
context
out of the 40 blue-collar workers in the
uae what
what is the estimated percentage of them
that could be transformed into skilled
workers
but they're just out of circumstance
positioned
as blue-collar workers in unskilled
positions
honestly a big chunk i would say easily
about 28 to 30 percent can be converted
wow um it's a big it's a big chunk um
there are
people there are first-timers that come
out here and then move up the ladder
there are people like that but a big
majority that you meet
are actually skilled people who
have ended up in the wrong employment
opportunities because of some middleman
in their home country you know so it's
about
the way you showcase your skills and how
you can put that forward
and what we do is we explicitly work
with ethical employers so we look for
employers who have
strong hr csr policies in place
we work with employers who have a focus
on diversity and inclusion because
um you know industries like
manufacturing for example
they don't employ a lot of women even
though a lot of women can actually be
skilled for that job
and in fact we tied up with one such
employer recently like dilton paints is
very focused on
diversity and inclusion and they want to
include more women in the workforce
so finding employers like that to work
with
is also very important because they
they create a great environment for the
candidate to thrive in
and so we identify employers like that
to work with but simultaneously you also
need to look at
the job seeker themselves and it's not
just about the skill that they have but
you know their personality also plays
a big role in who they are i mean i
we play somebody that was actually from
the logistics industry
and he was earning about 1500 durham's a
month right
wow and yeah he was earning 1500 dirhams
a month to start with
and um you know something happened at
his workplace one of his co-workers
had um said it was there was a racial
comment made towards him
so he decided to leave and he had a
30-day grace period within which
you know he had to find another
employment opportunity
and so that's when we got connected
and when we when we met him honestly he
is one of the most wonderful people
you'll meet he's so great to talk to and
he has so much
wisdom to give i mean there were things
that
like i learned as a person from him some
of his quotes were unbelievable
and that's when i realized that you know
this guy could actually be a great fit
in the hospitality industry
and he'd be able to earn even more than
what he was earning
in the logistic space and so we placed
him with a hospitality employer and
he i mean there was he almost had a 50
boost in his salary because you're not
only getting a base but you're also
getting
like tips from customers and you know
how to interact with people
that's your strength right so why not
use it
well i think that's just that's just
remarkable so if you look at the vision
you know a few years forward
what's gonna happen with with zoe z as
far as you're
seeing it honestly um for me like five
years down the line
i want to make sure that you know we
help educate
and find ethical employment
opportunities for one million job
seekers at least
and we and honestly the aim is to become
the go-to platform for the migrant
workforce we want to be that platform
that the migrant workforce can turn to
especially in relation to these specific
fields
and um essentially what that contributes
towards more than anything is helping
people find
like attain economic empowerment right
when you attain economic empowerment
you're
reducing inequalities in the community
you're creating greater diversity in the
community
and you're also having a ripple effect
so it's not just that one person that
you're impacting
but you're actually impacting five other
people in their families and creating
a better standard of living for them and
a better standard of living for
generations to come so it's not just
that one person you're impacting but it
has
a ripple effect across multiple
generations
i think i think that's wonderful and i i
want to spend more time talking about so
easy but i also want really want to
engage your brain on on the different
activities that you've done for example
the world economic forum and and
and the work that you're doing there
tell me how did you get involved with
that and what is the work that you're
doing
honestly it all comes down to networking
so
i've come to realize that that's a good
trait to have
um if you know how to like reach out to
the right people
and just basically know how to get
people
engaged with you and invest in your
invest in you as a person and also
invest
in your ideas right um so i actually
came across the global shapers community
at one young world
which is another youth a large youth
network and organization
um so i was a delegate speaker at uh one
young world 2018 in the hague
and somebody from the global shapers
community had seen me speak
and so we connected afterwards and she
told me about
this wonderful community and what i
really like about the
global shapers community honestly is the
fact that you have people
you have young leaders but who come from
so many different backgrounds
and who have so many different skill
sets but you're all working towards the
same vision you know you all want to
create
some form of social impact in the
community and the west's key pillars are
focused on education and employment um
equity and inclusion and the environment
so these are the three
main areas that they look at and these
are all three passion
passion areas for me so i joined
the global shapers community in early
and i was actually a part of helping one
of their
one of their now biggest projects so
global shapers dubai's current biggest
project
is with a foundation called the al
gore's foundation for
education and they provide scholarships
to underprivileged youth for
universities
and um the person that was leading this
initiative at the beginning i had
helped him assist with putting out the
first workshop and
you know taking them through project
management courses how to raise funding
um how to basically put your idea out
there and make sure that it grows
because practical experience at the end
of the day is very different to
what you learn at university or in a
classroom right
so that was one of the first education
initiatives that we've launched
now i'm the vice creator of the hub so
i'm also like part of the leadership
team and
helping manage it but also ensuring that
more projects are coming out in relation
to the other pillars as well
and uh we actually did a really cool
initiative recently like
um we launched something called the
elevate series so me and a
fellow global shaper were co-leading
that together and
um we did a pilot with an ngo in india
and the idea was to basically provide
skills training around building better
resumes presentations social media
skills using canva and
it was so interesting to see over the
span of two days we were able to reach
160 girls in 23 countries
and we never expected that so
i'm glad to see that you know it is it
is an initiative that has the potential
to grow and create
more sustainable impact and that's what
i love about the community as well
fantastic what are some you know nuggets
of wisdom that you can provide for
young entrepreneurs that or or just
young people in general that are looking
to affect social change that are looking
to make an impact
either in their local community or or
broader than that and you know
we you humbly forgot to mention that
you're you were chosen for forbes 30
under 30 for the amazing work that
you're doing
and but but but i'd love to hear a
little bit of your about your insight
as to how other young people can get
involved with similar initiatives
honestly i feel like if you are
passionate about something and you
believe
in your idea then first things first is
actually
lay out a budget that's the first thing
to do put a budget down
see if this is something that can be
viable
especially because you know you do want
to create impact in the world but you
also need to know how to survive
without being able to survive you won't
be able to affect that change
at a larger scale so yes start at the
grassroots level
but first things first lay down a budget
see if this is a viable project
see if there is a way to put it out and
then create a good story around it
because yes you can talk numbers and
numbers are very important
but in order to get people to invest in
you and believe in your idea you also
need to know how to communicate your
vision properly to others
um i think it's very important to kind
of combine those two skills together so
the storytelling balancing storytelling
with um the numbers that you that you
have in place that show that you know
this is
this is a big problem out there and
there is a viable solution which you
want to
provide and um finally i would say
one in like first things first invest in
yourself
learn as much as possible i went in
completely blind i was a first-line
entrepreneur i had no idea how to do any
of this stuff
but i had a great set of mentors and
honestly because of them
i've been able to come this far so
network
find yourself good mentors who can guide
you in the right direction
and do a lot of research and start
reaching out to the right
uh networks as well because especially
if you're a young entrepreneur you want
to meet people that are also young
entrepreneurs that have
gone along a similar journey and who
understand the process and who can guide
you so
do your research get access to networks
like one young world
one young world is a brilliant platform
for you to connect with
young innovators who are facilitating
change around the world
um so reach out to networks like one
young world reach out the networks like
the global shapers community
try to identify more networks that you
can be a part of where you can
connect with people randomly cold call
what's the worst that can happen i mean
somebody will say no
that's it it's okay if someone says no
no problem just move on to the next
thing and but
and but keep them posted on what's
happening obviously because if
one when you're when your company starts
to grow it will be likely that they will
come back and reach out themselves
so it may be a close to work now but
it'll open up
at a later stage so don't be deterred by
a no in any way frankly i got
so many no's in 2017 but
um there and obviously there were
self-doubt moments as well i was like oh
my god am i doing this the right way i
don't know what's going on
but you know one yes can really change
the entire game
so i love that spanana thank you so much
for being
so kind with your time and this was
really wonderful before we leave i have
to ask you the most difficult and most
important question
which is three words that reduce to
describe yourself
hmm that's a that's a very interesting
one it is a tough one that's like the
most difficult one i would say
right um
[Music]
i'm a people person so very friendly
empathetic
um i am also very
diverse as a person i know diverse isn't
exactly like a proper objective but i
would say diversity is a big part of me
based on like i mean so many different
factors so diversity
um and
curious i would say i'm curious
yeah thank you so much for joining me
here this was wonderful i can't wait to
share this with the world
and i can't wait to to have more
interaction both between the nations but
also maintaining this connection and
keeping open doors and then potentially
working together sometimes so thank you
very much
thank you thank you so much for having
me
take care bye
you